how do i build a network
across america of not just the survivors
but the helpers because that leads to so
many things for the rest of your life
for the rest of the movement that you're
you're trying to build and create this
is how you give hope by sharing your
story because if you're silent
it perpetuates the silence okay let me
give you a bonus hack
wendy in the house
hello
how are you doing evan i'm great how are
you is what is that for your what's that
thing behind you is that for your mail
what is that on the wall
well it's to keep me organized but let's
be honest it doesn't get used very often
so it's more for joe than anything else
so i'm just throwing it out there that
it's just to look pretty evan that's
what i like the radical honesty that's
great
well it looks like it's full of stuff
that needs to get done
yes yes yes and you know that's what you
were saying today you got you've got
that creative mode and then it's time to
launch and get things done and uh you
know that's what we're doing here right
now finding out how we can get some
things done so i'm just very very
grateful that i'm here with you
and gleaning from all your wisdom and
all your uh information that might
direct uh me in a more
um
with greater momentum what i want i love
it it's a magic word momentum yes yes it
is okay well tell me i mean you got a
youtube campaign or video like give me
the details and how can i help
okay
so
uh first of all i have to tell you i did
apply the two percent rule that you have
been uh able to help me understand back
in the spring i started to write my book
truth and dare daring to live your truth
in a fake world and in that book i
started to write my stories just very
heart compelled stories the reason why i
learned certain principles
and they're they're very real very
honest stories one of those stories i
felt very compelled to create a video
and while i was excited i got out and i
got the i i went out there found my
videographer started to put it together
it was a magical experience and once we
started to get into it i recognized the
story that i was sharing was all about
some sexual trauma that i had
experienced as a as a younger teenager
and
moving past that and into allowing
myself to unpeel the layers of trauma so
that the real me could show up in in
this heart-centered able to receive love
able to give love able to show up better
greater uh with with a greater capacity
and the video is beautiful it's got
actors actresses over 100 people in the
local community that came out the
videographers did an amazing job we
shot this very compelling beautiful
story
and on 9 11 very deliberately we
launched the campaign so we're moving
past me too and into time to heal that's
the movement that's the campaign and my
desire is to evoke that
that my my honest
full like this is a transparent story i
don't i don't hide anything i show
everything and i put it out there my
heart is out there so that i can help
women to understand that perhaps their
trauma is impeding them from living in
their highest and best is
masking them and i like to say the light
of the soul is hard and challenging to
see when it's shadowed by the trauma of
yesterday
so
that is really what this movement is hey
sisters it's now time to write it's
night now time to heal the time is now
so that's it we did it on 9 11 because
the trauma of our country brought us
together as americans and so 911 was
also a start of let's unite together
those of you that are part of this me
too but now let's lift each other and
help each other become the best versions
of ourself by lending support by loving
each other by telling each other
different ways that we were able to heal
and grow
so
here we are 9 11 the video did well um
it's but here's the thing um i also
recognize in me too
that uh a gal by the name of tarara
burke actually launched that movement
back in 2007
and then it really didn't become a huge
movement until 2017 when alyssa milano
came out and said hey make sure that
everybody hashtags me too so that's when
it really became big well i'm not alyssa
mulatto i'm not in the public eye like
that so where does a girl like me really
start to take off and what would you
encourage me to do to help gather those
that need this in their lives so that's
why i'm coming to you is to to get that
uh more of a a very uh deliberate
actionable plan
we did the creation now it's time to put
it into to a plan
all right this is great there's so much
in here this is amazing lots to work
with um first up like congrats on doing
it congrats on writing the book and
sharing your soul and like
especially when you talk about trauma
that's so
hard to
get it out there like you feel naked
sharing this and who's gonna judge me
and
yeah so that takes a tremendous amount
of courage and
your
willingness to be seen and share makes
other people who've been through it feel
less alone like if one person looks at
that and say oh i'm not
like i'm not alone other people have
gone through this you know you give hope
like this is how you give hope by
sharing your story
uh because if you're silent
it perpetuates the silence
exactly yes and when we bring it out
into the light the shame can no longer
exist anymore right um so absolutely no
this is a story i never thought i would
share like this is my inner circle story
evan this is not a story i was gonna
give to the world but i felt like if my
heart said if you will do this and
you're courageous and brave it will
impact and help someone else so yes
thank you
well and i love that you went from like
the idea to the book and then one of the
stories that becomes a video it's like
it's great this these are all you know
the seeds that who knows what it's gonna
what forest will be created from that
little you know sapling that you planted
on 9 11.
um
okay couple things in here the first is
recognizing that this is a movement and
this is an ongoing this is a mission
this is not just like how do we promote
this for the next week this is forever
this is you know
like let's get eyes on this thing and
it's it's this is what happens a lot of
times when people are launching books
like oh i'm just gonna it's out cool
let's try to hit a list and then that's
it as opposed to no there's a movement
that i'm trying to build and when you
talk about me too taking a decade or
whatever it was for it to actually start
taking
taking shape and getting attention
that's right the work and it wasn't a
failure in the first 10 years could have
gone faster yes
but there's the work behind the scenes
in the trenches planting you know
watering nurturing
that seed to become something much
bigger like two things one for the video
right now that's already come out
i would be
linking it everywhere that you've got
it's in the bio of your ig it's the
trailer on your youtube page it's in the
newsletter that you put out on your
email list it's uh in the ps of every
email in your signature and your email
like ps check out the story on whatever
um okay
it's like any communication that's being
sent out
it's there for people to go and
potentially check out so okay um you
know the ps on mine is join my discord
so any email that i send off it's like
join the discord but yours could be
ps like i don't know how many emails you
send out a day you know maybe it's 10 if
it's 20 maybe it's 200
but everybody who it's just
automatically kind of baked in there ps
here it is so anywhere where you're
creating
any kind of content website social email
videos bio links the the video is there
that's an easy starting point
uh the second thing is because of the
youtube video i would look at how well
the video did retention wise and see if
there might be
edits or tweaks or hacks like is there a
cut down version are there moments when
you lose the retention
because
if people are dropping off if we cut
that part out the video has a better
chance to
succeed and win
the good news is evan it's 6 minutes and
53 seconds and the attention is there
there let's go the whole thing so yeah
cool
news but thank you i'm gonna continue
now that could have been because the
first initial push were people in my
tribe so we'll keep looking at that sure
and and then you can split test the
thumbnail and what's our title and what
we're going to call it now like if
you're thinking more long term in
reaching out right even just on this
video let alone like we'll move to the
whole movement afterwards but just for
the video
what's the main like so me too obviously
everybody knows
it's time to heal or like what's the
what's the main
phrase hashtag time
number two heal
that is
yeah time to heal
perfect
any uh groups
any
uh coaches any contents being put out
like any any uh i don't know how like if
somebody has this
trauma where are they going who are they
reaching out to what groups are they
joining whether they're paid or free or
meetups or
whatever it is
to
have that video potentially be a part of
the healing process for them
so
if there's uh
anywhere down from like a shelter that
people might be going to or religious
organizations or groups or
like where do people go to connect and
start to share their story and then you
connecting with the connectors
and putting this video on their
attention that maybe your video is the
thing that helps explain something in a
way that they couldn't explain or just
another way to be able to see it so
you know if i look at
i don't know what the i don't know
enough about like the trauma sexual
trauma world to know like where people
go and it may not be as organized as
something like alcoholics anonymous but
if we use aaa just as an example
imagine if your video was talking about
healing from that as opposed to sexual
trauma and then imagine if your videos
was played on day one of every aaa
meeting
just big into the process right
so who are the like if i wanted to do
that who who do i have to talk to inside
of aaa is it the whoever's like the the
ceo of aa is it on an individual chapter
level do they have a newsletter
that
they're all talking to each other like
how does the curriculum get organized
that's not an overnight thing
right but it's a movement you know and
it's valuable and the story that you
told
in the video in a year and two years and
five years is still
valuable it's still relevant it's not
just a 2022 september 11th thing so like
the timing of the launch was very cool
and now it's in a year it's still just
as helpful and relevant
so where are these women going right now
and how can you be a part of that
healing journey to assist the assisters
so a lot of teachers use my videos in
their classrooms
and
i got a the number of teachers who've
written to me to say like thank you for
not putting swearing in your videos
because i play it to my grade 8
classrooms as part of like homeroom
every day or something and that was
never actually my intention we just
moved to swear words because i don't
swear it's just
my own thing
um but what a great like byproduct right
so if i wanted to get into like now it's
just a bunch of teachers who are doing
it but if i wanted to
be in the education system now it's like
okay how do i get more teachers to play
my videos how do i
who do i have to talk to was it at the
teacher level or superintendent level or
etc right and it may be different for
different states and different you know
counties so that becomes the work and
maybe that's you maybe that's your tribe
maybe that's your assistant it's like
how do we
who are the people who are who are the
helpers and how do we help the helpers
so you're not just helping the end of
the actual
uh survivors but you're helping the
helpers
so we're making a list of like a
thousand helpers across america
love that love who are those people and
then how can i help you
how can i assist you and the first
lead-in is with the video
this is an easy this is a story they're
going to heal through it it's not the
only thing you have your own methodology
cool but this might add to somebody's
healing right um right
what that then does is help you build a
much bigger movement on top of just the
video where imagine that you had your
list of a thousand helpers and you're in
contact with them and they know who you
are and you're all
working towards the same thing of now
it's time to heal maybe not like exactly
how you see it but they're they're doing
their own version of it too
when you want to launch the next thing
your book your next book your mastermind
your own training centers across america
or your healing centers across like now
you have people who can support you and
join you and you've been working with
and training with
and so there's like the immediate
strategy just around how do i get this
video out
but there's the ongoing of how do i
build a network
across america of not just the survivors
but the helpers because that leads to so
many things for the rest of your life
for the rest of the movement that you're
you're trying to build and create so
that becomes a call to action like you
your followers your audience your
newsletter like let's work on a list
let's get a thousand people who are
helping
who are helping the survivors so we want
to help the helpers and then you start
reaching out and it could be instagram
twitter you know email phone calls
and to to
not do it alone because i can feel over
like how do i get a thousand people
across the american feel like it's gonna
it's gonna end up like that box behind
you that then it's just like something
to look at
it's like it's not happening
uh
and and so the easiest way to do it is
you you put a time on your calendar that
tuesday afternoons is movement outreach
time and you're trying to figure out how
do i
half the day or whatever fits into your
calendar but like this is important for
for you for the women you're helping and
for the rest of your life like you're
going to be 90 years old still caring
about this absolutely
if anything even more like like no this
is so important that you get this right
so yeah so it's it's amazing the short
term of this one video but there's so
many of these videos and projects and
courses and
healing centers and vr and all the stuff
that will come
because unfortunately
you know when you're 90 people will
still be
experiencing sexual trauma and will
still need to heal you know yeah so this
is a lifeline lifetime mission that
we're on um
so if you set you know site tuesday
afternoons i'm gonna spend four hours
every tuesday doing this work and the
outreach and it's you finding the names
it's it's dming people and messaging
people and asking for help even like you
did this right like you kira mentioned
to me that you wanted to do this and so
here we are i'm talking about this right
here we are yeah
so it's getting
like enlisting help
and it may be a no you know like i could
have said hey i don't have time right
now right it's probably not going to be
i hate you wendy forget about it right
like you're probably not going to get
those kind of responses um but for some
people maybe it's just the wrong time
yeah and it's not now but it's not a
personal rejection of you and the
mission of what you're doing
but but the important part is to not try
to do everything
on your own
and to build the list of a thousand
people on your own and to do the
outreach all on your own because it's
lonely you lose motivation and it just
feels overwhelming that this is not
possible
right um
so part of the work on a tuesday
afternoon or whatever you set aside is
how do i enlist people to help me like
hey do you want to help me find on
people do you set up people in different
states is the goal to have how many
states are there in the u.s 52
50 50 what do i think too is alaska not
a state
i i guess if you thought puerto rico
or you know those types of things that
make you maybe a couple that's right
you're kidding i'm canadian so whatever
[Laughter]
uh but like if you wanted to have a
captain for every state and now you're
recruiting 50 captains or whatever you
want to leaders or whatever language you
want to use but now they're responsible
for their state
right and so okay you're you're you're a
new york champion and you're arizona i
need i need a
i need a ohio champion who's going to be
my ohio and like i'll do that i'll i'll
help wendy
and then tuesday afternoons maybe you're
meeting with all your champions for half
an hour to brainstorm ideas and like
here's what i'm doing okay cool and that
might what somebody's doing in ohio
might
inspire the person in new york to do
some outreach into the sharing and it
becomes something much bigger than
just
one video which kind of started the
whole thing right right
but if you don't like schedule time and
you don't
ask people for help then it stays small
yes or it stays that like list of ideas
on the wall behind right it's like you
know there's so much good that's here
it's like until we do something about it
nothing ends up happening the other
thing i would look at is how much work
you want to do actually helping the
survivors and how can you do that and i
don't know survivors is the right word
of what you would want to call it i
think that's beautiful i mean survivors
i i like to consider this movement as
taking that victimization of me too and
and moving it to victor right
now
and and
just allowing themselves that is now an
experience that we had it's something
that has shaped
how we have cut you know how how we've
shown up in the world but
now we have more compassion now we have
more empathy now we can connect and
especially once we dismantle all of the
trauma and the trauma responses that we
have based on that trauma now we can
really show up now we can really shine
our light and absolutely i think
survivor is a great
uh word but i think victor is an even
more empowering word right and and those
are exactly like we're putting into
pieces lots of different things like
groups where we can collectively share
ideas be that that soft place to land
for individuals because my first thing
my first encouragement is start
somewhere
start anywhere it's it's kind of like
your two percent start somewhere do it
once we marinate we will talk ourselves
out of it every single time so if our
heart leads and we start that movement
and we take some action wherever that is
even if it's just
starting with the facebook group we took
some action now we get ideas now our
heart is open now we start to see what
we can do in order to heal because the
world needs individuals that are in that
healing phase it invites i believe
healing women will heal a broken and
hurt world because it invites the men to
participate and then it also allows the
children to see what does happy look
like what does joyful look like what
does self-confident look like oh mom
is self-confident mom loves herself mom
shows up in this world and she doesn't
hide and she doesn't self-betray and she
she shines her life so that's what i see
with this movement it really does have
the the capacity to impact
millions of lives because it starts with
the individual goes to the family goes
to the community right so absolutely i
think that it's important for us to have
resources for them to start where do you
start you know if you've not gone down
this road where do you start
so the strategies that we just talked
about will work the language and the
naming you can finesse and play with
right so like if we're having a a
champion or a captain of each state
maybe you don't like captain or champion
like i'm just trying i'm searching for
names but like having somebody in chat
or or you can like it's a heroine or
it's a like uh
i don't know whatever like whatever you
made meditate on and you pray on it and
and like boom the word enters your mind
but that idea and it should be
empowering i'm using more generic terms
but it could be
it could be like we're all our own joan
of arc and like you're you're the joan
it's like whatever it could be
like the strategy will work just but
language becomes an important part of
any movement so it should be an
empowering position that i am the blank
for
ohio
um
and survivor cool if we want to call it
the victors that they may not identify
themselves as a victor yet but that's
where they want to get to
um
typically if you want to scale it
then the work becomes helping the
helpers
so the people who already have a
community so that you don't have to
build community one by one
there already there's here's this person
who's got a community of a thousand
women who are who've been through this
drama like how do i get into that circle
uh and if you're gonna help people then
if you're going to help the survivors
and it's going to be something that has
potential to scale
so like this
we're doing it as an instagram i'm
helping you and hopefully
yes you are absolutely
and it's an instagram live that then
maybe it gets turned into a youtube
video so that hopefully other people
get the value from it as well
so it's not just a one-on-one
right so it's a one-on-one but it's at
scale so if you're going to be helping
survivors
then do you have your own show where
you're helping survivors do you do an
instagram live once a day with a
survivor and you
you coach her or you help her you just
hug her or like depending on where
they're at you meet people where they're
at you take them as far as they can go
some people just sharing their story and
not being judged and holding the space
is the beginning of healing without even
telling them anything about what to do
just listening
and
being an ear and not judging them is
a great starting point for healing so do
you have some kind of show or some kind
of at scale whether it's instagram or
tick tock or youtube uh or newsletter
where you're sharing people's stories or
just something where it's not
that's the one-on-one work because i
love the one-on-one it's my favorite
like this is awesome
and it doesn't scale and so if i want to
impact the world i need to be doing it
at scale and so
same thing for you
uh if you want like how much one-on-one
work do you want to do
and is there a way to turn it into
something that
other people can learn from as well
because when
sharon from nebraska comes on and shares
her story and you're talking to her and
you're helping her
people watching will see themselves and
sharing and
how courageous she is and like maybe i
don't have to suffer alone too
and that becomes a goal like hopefully
people watching this
or maybe the replay on youtube
uh if they have a movement that they're
trying to get out to the world they can
use a lot of the same strategies we
talked about even if
trauma and sexual abuse is like not the
things we're trying to
to solve right
right um so like those two things is
that help the helpers and
some kind of
helping the survivors at scale
through content
um but then that just is
rinse and repeat and rinse repeat for
the next
80 years of your life
beautiful
i can see it i think this is a great
great uh it's been amazing with what
you've been able to offer me today and i
think it's a great uh starting point for
me to i i can see the vision a lot
bigger
than i did before
and
uh so i really feel like this has been
incredibly helpful
i love it win
to win win that's great and like the
best part is you're doing it you know a
lot of times we may feel like
it's not enough because it like how many
people are struggling with this how many
women
across america around the world have
struggled with this it's probably even
worse in other countries
uh i mean i don't know the stats but
i wouldn't they say one in every three
females but i'm gonna tell you
i would say
it's much higher than that i would say
it's two and three
i'm globally in some countries it's
definitely way worse
yes you were like i would agree with
that
and i don't know like how much you want
to dive into that world or not uh but
like even just in america alone or
through canada in there too you know
it's uh it's it's a big deal
and a lot of times you can look at like
it's not enough like i wrote a book and
i made a video and it's not
it's not enough it's not hitting enough
people and like who am i to go and do
this insane giant thing
and it's just every day taking another
step
and
you know the if you look at me too when
she started it a decade before alyssa
milano like you'll have your own alyssa
milano moments yeah with it too but only
if you keep
every day laying another brick or or
planting another seed or watering that
tree a little bit more
like in the day-to-day work that is
fulfilling in itself yeah like
helping the helper or doing energy live
with somebody who
like you help that one person it may not
feel like it's doing the big mission but
all those little
bricks that you
you plant every day end up you look back
like oh my god i built a house this is
crazy
yeah
that's beautiful i love this i think
this is super helpful and gives me a
very very specific way to approach my
next steps
honestly the biggest thing is the
calendar like now back to like dreaming
in the clouds and how we're going to
change the world and like that like
making it tactical like yeah there has
to be
a couple hours at least every week that
you block off and you guard and defend
and say like this is super important to
me and
90 of the time when that's there like
i'm gonna do it like there may be some
cases where
something happens but for the most part
like you're showing up and doing it and
even if you don't know what you're going
to do on that day like here's tuesday
afternoon i'm going to spend four hours
work on this mission and i don't know
what to do next cool
you still work on it you pray on it and
you meditate on it and you ask for
guidance on it it's like that's in your
calendar and something has to get done
this week and some weeks will be better
you know and more productive than others
but
like if it's not in the calendar
it doesn't get done and remains just
like hope and dream and it
what often happens and i'm not saying
it's with you but what often happens is
like these starting stops and starting
stops or it's like yeah like book
massive progress yes out cool and then
nothing for a while oh video like
massive progress cool and and then
nothing for a while where the real gains
are made in like the everyday every week
the consistency that i said i was gonna
do it it's not as sexy it's not as maybe
fun as doing a new like
video project but
if it's just these kind of quick hits of
projects it doesn't end up actually
having a huge impact that you're trying
to have where it's it's just showing
every week even when you doubt yourself
you don't know what to do but it's in
the calendar and i'm gonna i'm gonna do
something to move it forward a little
bit
no
beautiful and you're exactly right i
mean it is in that long-term vision
the the long-term goal and and helping
it's that snowball effect and so i think
that
i'm going to be putting in my calendar
some non-negotiable time every single
week just like you mentioned
uh and i love the idea of having
instagram lives and talking to survivors
victors about their stories and really
helping to identify the blocks that are
keeping them from hanging on to it what
what are the trauma responses that they
keep finding themselves gravitating to
and how can we start to disband that so
i think it'd be a beautiful opportunity
to seal
for others to see how this process works
and
so i think those are some fantastic
starting points i even have a couple of
organizations already that do work with
trauma survivors and are interested in
showing my video at trainings at uh you
know one of the things that i first
started with at my first the first point
that i was going through my healing
journey was a trauma-based retreat that
allowed me to learn how trauma stored
house trauma is released and that
organization's huge and they are they
are looking at the video right now we'll
see what happens great okay let me give
you a bonus hack just around that
so okay so that's a huge organization
that you're going after has any any
organization actually like done it yet
not yet we just did this on sunday and
those emails and connections went out
yesterday so i'm just waiting for some
responses these are i i included people
that know these individuals personally
so that's not just me throwing out a an
email and hoping that it lands
cool yeah perfect you're already using
your advocates and your champions that's
great okay uh so what you do is once you
get one
we want to use their name in future
outreaches
okay so
like what's the name of one
like what's one that you'd love to have
or like maybe not like the giant huge
one but what's an example of like a name
of one that you would want to have um so
it used to be called the unique
foundation uh which is that unique
makeup company but now it's called the
supriya organization
uh or sopria foundation so that would be
the one that i would just celebrate
uh in order to to get on their radar
and where are they based
here in utah just oh there you go and do
they do they help mostly like utah women
or is it a it's a cross
so
so that now becomes like tuesday time or
whenever you know what whatever
afternoon time like supriya is
has dedicated energy towards it you know
and like and even though you feel you've
done everything you prey on it and like
okay what else can i do to help get the
supriya thing through who do i need to
talk to what do i need to manifest like
let's go get the supreme thing has to
happen and being super clear with the
people in your tribe in your audiences
say
i want to get this at supriya meetings
events
retreats
trainings whatever they're doing right
okay because people will then like when
you're specific like that people will
find ways to try to help you versus
i want to get this to the world cool but
like what's what do i do when do you how
can i help you you know yeah um so
once you get to priya
or you get some other organization to do
it even if they're much smaller
you then use their name for all the
future outreaches that you're doing well
like supriya played it in there as a
part of their retreat
and you mentioned their name in all the
future emails so that there's a little
bit more legitimacy and credibility that
like they're not the first to do this
and that there's this is valuable and
worth doing
uh and you the bigger names you get the
more you
use the bigger names right like if i'm
trying to book somebody on my interview
show
to come on
um
you're like we're trying to we're trying
to get oprah to come on and do the
interview right yes which is great oprah
is doing like no interviews right now
like come on oprah make it happen let's
go oh what happened need to happen
you know my team would like name drop
the people who we've had on that she
might recognize you know that maybe you
were on her show where there's like
deepak chopra and anthony robbins and
matthew mcconaughey and you know those
kind of people
uh now because we've had them on and i
can use them so you're using those names
and the bigger names you get like if i
get oprah on then i'm going to use
oprah's name in my future emails and
maybe drop somebody else right so you
build up
the second thing inside of that is if
you get
whoever supriya
you look at who's following them on
social
okay
look who follows them on instagram look
at who follows them on tick tock look at
who follows them on facebook look who
follows it on twitter
who's following them and they'll be like
a supreme will probably have a lot of
people following them i don't know how
big if they're a global organization
they probably have significant following
maybe not millions but i don't know
um but who are the helpers who are
following them not the individuals
okay
and then you outreach to them
and there'd be a whole bunch of
organizations you've never heard of who
may not be in utah or like they're
smaller or or maybe even bigger you just
never heard of them
and when you outreach to them you say
well supriya is using our video in their
training
now they're much more likely to listen
to you because you already know that
they care about supriya because they're
following supriya
beautiful so if you if you wrote to me
to say supriya is using my training how
about we show your video like i don't
know who supre is so it means nothing
yeah but if they're already following
supriya then you already know that they
know
supriya and they care about them
otherwise they probably wouldn't be
following them
and so that can that can one be a great
way to build the list of of helpers to
do outreach to
and also really dramatically increase
your chances of
getting a yes from them and again it
doesn't have to be supriya level like
maybe there's just some
local utah church who has a women's
support group that has 40 people show up
every week
and that's the first like it doesn't
have to be superior level global
organization it's the local church group
and they have 400 followers on
instagram and you get in and your videos
being played at the next church
session that they're going to be doing
and whoever is leading it says wow
wendy's video was amazing thank you so
much
then the 400 people who are following
them on instagram
are all great potential outreaches to
you especially if they're not just the
survivors but they're the
the helpers they're organizations
and you start to build this connection
of all these people you can reach out to
and then you use the the church group
in the name in the in the in the message
out to them say hey well this church
group just used the video i'd love to
show it to you as well
and it means something to them because
they're following them on instagram
wow
that's amazing
no wonder you have three and a half
million followers your bonus hacks bonus
hacks i love it cool well thank you
wendy for people who want to find the
video or learn more about you we're like
where are they going
okay so on instagram it's wendy.bundle
uh two n's two l's n is an ansi youtube
wendy bunnell uh facebook wendy bundle
all the things illuminate your essence
and also wendybundle.com is my website
so you can find me anywhere by my name i
love it and we love you thank you wendy
hey we'll see you soon
okay
take care
hi
liz grant in the house how you doing so
well thank you so much this is so
amazing it looks beautiful where you are
i know i made it that way because the
other way is kind of ugly
oh you know what
huh do you know how i heard that is when
you said i made it that way it's like
you made the weather that way
i've been working on that too i like it
ellie's like wow i like liz is thinking
bigger here this is i made it that way
can you come to toronto because it's
raining right now we could use rain in
california though i made it that way i
love it cool well welcome back to mover
makers this is um
awesome having you back in i love you i
love your energy and your vibe and your
smile and
how can i help what do you got thank you
so much well i want to do this first if
you'll let me i'm using my time um so
these are the top 12 things i've learned
from evan so 12 is that 12 000 videos
later you're likely to still have
resistance filming but just film and
post
11 is the equipment doesn't matter just
post
10 is nobody cares about your makeup
just post i don't believe that one but
um
nine do it because you may inspire
someone uh like you who's five years
behind where you are now
clean your house because research shows
that you're more stressed when it's
cluttered
seven get outside start moving videos
are easy when you feel like you're
moving or talking to someone or in a
parking lot at costco while you're
waiting for your wife to finish shopping
nina
um
have courage feel the fear and post
anyway
five keep going um have one business
model which is what i'd love to talk to
you about and stick with that until you
get some success and then start trying
to do everything else um
serve others serve a higher purpose
believe and you've shown me i'm gonna
get emotional but you show me you
believe in me and it means so much to me
also my mom and my stepdad who've made
some tremendous sacrifices so i can be
in movement makers like canceling disney
plus
um
and number one if you're not posting
it's probably because you're just
spiritually constipated
you just need to get going you need some
momentum and we need to get your book i
love it well first off what an amazing
list thank you for the tribute i
appreciate you liz that's that's
fantastic i'm speechless i'm just taking
it in thank you oh thank you for
everything so well let's dive in how do
you mean what do you got how can i help
what do we want to work on business
model posting yeah well i'm a bit of a
mess with posting um i'm having trouble
with my computers both of them don't
seem to be able to handle basic
editing and imovies a nightmare for
doing like i'll film a long set and i
just want to splice all those up and
post them and um i'm having trouble i've
tried all different apps i
and
i've tried just doing it on the phone so
i i just got a gal from fiverr
to help me and she loves comedy and
she's got good comedic timing so i don't
think i need to tell her in and out
points
and um and i think i can afford her for
a little bit she's super cheap she's a
student so um
so that's like at some point i'd love
some guidance on i even downloaded the
open source software
for video editing and i can't even
launch that on my
computer so
but i really feel like um i'm confused
about
well right now what we what jessica and
i were doing when we were working
together and i could afford her was we
were trying to get corporate comedy gigs
so that i could secure that income
and um it's really hard through linkedin
to try to message people who don't want
to hear from you you know and whatever
and i'd love to be able to run ads on
linkedin
but i don't think i have the money right
now to do that
um so what i pivoted to
most recently the economy just as you
know something happened on top of a
bunch of other things happening and
i um
started doing shows online which um it's
just to my facebook friends and i just
said hey if you feel like
tipping or not whatever and that was how
i was able to pay my rent like it was
really successful and
i have a lot of different topics that i
was doing shows for like i have pets
and then i have um dating material and
then so of all these different themes um
and i was just making it quick because
no one really wants to be on zoom that
much
so i was just doing like quick 20-minute
um
sets and just riffing with people and
having a good time and um
and i was just blown away it was way
more than if i would have sold tickets
you know
so what i'm wondering is
should i keep and then also um doing
shows in people's backyards
so
the same thing just like okay you know
you want to tip me and and the joke is
that i have two netflix specials but
netflix doesn't know about it yet
so i've been trying to figure out well
what um
branding or what persona do i want and i
and maybe it doesn't even matter but i i
feel like they're two really different
shows and i have two really different
podcast ideas
so i don't know really what i should be
doing so nothing gets done and if you go
back to the list of the 12 things
yeah
a lot of it was like
just post
[Laughter]
i i hear you in my head yes absolutely
and here's like you know
in watching some of your stuff and
looking at you even looking at your ig
before going on here you know you posted
a couple times this month
and it doesn't have to be you
on stage it could just be you
talking to the camera i mean it's social
commentary your stuff is you you see
something
i'm sure hanging out with you there'd be
there'd be jokes all day
your comments if you like riffing with
people in your facebook group then all
of those that becomes content yeah and
honestly be looking at
three posts a day
across tick tock and instagram okay
which starts to build your brand because
you all you need is for one of those is
to pop that somebody says
who is this person who is as liz woman
i've never heard of her before and then
they start diving into everything else
that you're doing
i love the betting on yourself when
doing your own shows
you know like asking for donations doing
your shows if the model becomes these
are is this inside a facebook group or
this is just your facebook friends
that's my facebook friends i just put
something on there and then invited
people
i'd love to take this show on the road
like even if it's still you just in your
home or wherever you are doing like how
do we expand it beyond your facebook
friends
so that when people are watching this or
people who are watching your content
when they see it they know that there's
a show happening
whether it's every week or every two
weeks or once a month or i don't know
how long it it takes you to kind of get
ready or if you're just jamming with
people
and riffing then you could you could do
a weekly show yeah yeah and i have
enough material to do weekly shows and
do themed shows and topics like i have i
have 35 minutes on costco that
you know i could do a whole thing on
costco
i want to hear that one that'd be good
uh but the way you're doing it right now
is people would have to
be your facebook friend to be able to
see the show correct right right so we
need something a little more
open whether it's a facebook the easiest
thing might just be a facebook group
oh
where you launch your own facebook group
okay you can still invite people in
and then you go live inside that
facebook group
once a week you've got your friday night
special or or whatever it is was there a
certain time you're doing them
no but mostly like saturdays 7 30. okay
saturday 7 30. yeah you can ask your
friends and post on your facebook to
people to join the group yeah so hey i'm
joining this group i'm having this group
you know liz grant comedy come join in
and the next time i do my show you'll be
the first to know
and then anybody who follows you you've
got almost a thousand followers right
now on instagram
you send a video message to everybody
one by one say hey i'm starting a new
i'm starting a new group okay
come join me and make that the link in
your bio
okay so what i want to do
what i want to do what my idea is i
guess for you my my invitation to you
there instead of like hey you have to do
this liz is
taking two paths right one is let's
build the liz grant we got to build your
brand up people need to know about you
which will lead to lots of opportunities
whether it's a netflix show corporate
gigs can you come speak at my event we
need somebody to open for our
event whatever like people will just
think you're funny and then find ways to
include you in the stuff that they're
doing but they have to know who you are
and they have to find you and they have
to think you're funny right
so that's the three times a day posting
okay tick tock and instagram reels
okay and it's just
like you find something and you get
inspired and you make a
you make something quick and funny and
and not having like don't worry about
the edit there is no editing no edits
zero edits
okay like you you're you open it up and
you you film from your phone
you know 45 seconds to a minute you're
outside costco and you get upset at
something
you film it and then you post it to
tick-tock and to instagram reels
three times a day instagram reels
instagram reels and tick-tock three
times a day
okay stuff that's happening here's my
breakfast and what's so funny about the
oatmeal it looks like a whatever and
then you just and right
yeah
something just quick
okay
one you'll get better at it like you're
already great at what you do but like in
in how do you tell like
micro 45 second jokes but also knowing
that there's three coming up tomorrow
too you're less concerned about this one
having to be so great and edited
perfectly it's like whatever i don't
even remember what i did last week
because there's so much that you're
you're creating today and tomorrow
totally and then some of those will hit
and some of them will then lead to
people wanting to find out about you
okay
so that is building the brain but that
is a i mean it's the consistent work to
put in and you never know when
something's going to hit
right so that but but that's like our
we're
we're we're taking our at bats you know
we're taking our bats until we get a a
single or double or a home run right yep
yep but if you're not swinging you're
not stepping up you're not going to get
any hits right
uh meanwhile so that like that's going
to lead to big things for you and things
that you can't even predict at this
point yeah somebody like wants you to do
uh to open for them on stage somebody
wants you to
do the set at their wedding some like
you never know you know their pets are
getting married and they want you to
come and uh
who knows like
crazy things will happen you know a new
costco opens and they want you to be the
oh
that would be heaven you want to open it
up like you never know where it's going
to go honestly because of what you do
there's there's no one defined path only
for you it's not like you only have to
have a book and that's the only way that
you can win exactly so that's why you
need to have so many at bats out there
and lots of ways that people can can
find you in different angles and paths
through yeah so that helps build your
brain
but how do you how do you feed yourself
and pay the bills and all that well
that's through your weekly specials okay
that we're driving people towards now
okay so the link in your bio you have
you have a bio link on instagram we have
a bio link on tick tock you link them
both to your facebook group
and it's like join me for my weekly
comedy special okay cool
and then when people show up then that's
when you do your usual thing and you're
asking for tips and donations and
explaining where you're at and also ask
for help it's like
when you're asking for the donations or
the tips i like tips better than
donations me too yeah ask them for help
it's like hey if anybody knows
you know if
somebody needs a comedian to open up
for their
wedding or their event or their xyz
yeah keep me in mind
because people may not even know to
think about like they love you they just
had a laugh but they don't they don't
even know how they might be able to help
that's true
so as part of a tip you you also have a
call to action
yeah and that's a very simple like to
set up a facebook group you can do that
today
i know you don't need to have any fancy
like you need a computer with chrome
okay and you go to facebook set up a
group and there it is the liz grant
comedy group okay and you already know
how to go live inside facebook so cool
so now that's just going to go live
inside your facebook group
and now we want to get people in
so it's not just your friends watching
you but other people who now are going
to discover you well i was thinking
about trying to capture their email
through the lead magnet and then do it
on zoom but um
what do you think about that
i just don't want to add layers of
complexity for you okay i appreciate
that you can
you know like this might be liz grant in
in a year
you know
but like i want to get you moving and i
want to get you paid
yeah
and those two things will allow lots of
other things to happen
you're right like to create a lead
magnet and then create a landing page
and then to create the
email tie-ins and all that it's like
yeah you could you could do that but
you're probably gonna
be frustrated by it yeah yeah you're
right i got a real short attention span
and low frustration tolerance for sure
so i'd rather you spend that time making
three ig reels and three tick tocks a
day and then doing your weekly show
so it's like
the most basic of of business plans but
it's super easy for you to execute yeah
it is you just have a facebook group
you just say you're going live every
whatever friday at 7 30 or saturday at
whatever
yeah and then you message all your
friends
to join you there and you and you
message your all your followers on
instagram
like do do 30 people a day
okay send a quick video message
and say hey
susan thank you for following me i
appreciate it i've started a new
facebook group and in there i'm going
live
uh once a week with my comedy show i
hope you can join me the link's in my
bio happy monday
believe i would add to believe at the
end you don't have to
hashtag evan carmichael i mean that's
what i do every morning every morning i
go for a walk i like it when i'm moving
around outside and i'm
not just in my office like i like the
nature and the energy
so i'll go for a walk and i'll send 30
to 50
dms over video every day sometimes the
move makers sometimes they're friends
sometimes they're people who followed me
just a lot of random stuff um
yeah and like today i was walking
outside in my undershirt and a weighted
vest on and i'm walking around with this
making videos in the park you know it's
like
go it's that like that's the best yeah
so if you have a thousand followers
you know you do 30 people a day
just let them know about what you're
doing and that's that facebook group
page is the default link in your bio for
anything that you're creating yeah and
then right now it's a little bit of
hustle to like actual manual outreach
like you're going to ask your friends
and you're going to ask all your
followers one by one not a post because
the post nobody's going to see it but a
dm people see
and they're already following you so
it's not like we're spamming people it's
like hey susan thank you for following
me yeah i've started a new facebook
group i'm doing my show once a week
there i'd love to have you if you want
to join the links in my bio happy monday
next like
doing 30 of those is not
it's not that difficult and then as
we're making three reels and three tick
tocks a day
that's now the group that people are
going to go to by default
so they're going to watch your thing
who's this liz grant and then they see
the link they click on it they join your
group
and then we use the weekly show
as your chance to start making like a
little bit of money and then more money
and then more money and then people love
you and people find opportunities and
then the world opens up where you're
yeah doing all sorts of crazy things
makes sense
people just don't know you enough yeah i
know
um
okay that's great so what about um in
terms of a podcast um
now i know this can be super complicated
i do not think that i can produce it
myself like if i got someone else who
was
interested in handling all the technical
and the posting and the audio because i
started doing um it was called massaging
comedy so and i am a massage therapist
but um i'm massage comedians so
um we had one really good show but the
problem was i need more equipment
because the audio levels were too
different
so um
so i don't know if i should like
continue down with that podcast or just
do a podcast about how to make things
funner or fun that i find or interview
fun and funny people or
don't worry about it and just work on
what you the assignment you just gave me
i would definitely work on the
assignment i just gave you first okay
that is like because that feeds you
yeah and starts to relieve some of the
stress around money and it and it's the
most effective way to build your brand
because we now need more people to find
you now if you're saying i got this evan
this is easy like dm 30 people a day who
follow me cool set up the facebook group
that's done today and three tick tocks a
day and ig reels no problem like done
cool
what's next yeah you want to do a
podcast awesome or you want to do
something else that's in that
genius head of yours cool thank you but
let's let's get the first part
down like that's the foundation for you
building
both the short-term business and the
long-term business for you
yeah you're right
what do you think about tick-tock um
lives where you do battles with people
or i was thinking about even doing like
i have so many jokes on on cards so like
when i do like
comedy tarot like oh this joke's for you
i like it
uh tick tock tick tock lives are
interesting um i still like instagram
lives more but tick tock is
uh it's worth playing in and having fun
with with the lives the best part about
doing the live sorry the the just
posting regulated tick tock or ig reels
is it could be the same video
so the 45 second cost code joke that
you're gonna tell
you film it with your phone
vertical and then you can post it to
both tik tok and instagram vertical okay
yeah has to be vertical so like what we
just talked about
uh that's that's the assignment for the
next you know three to six months
and make me like that has to happen
every day
okay like that's our that's our basic
pass that's like brushing your teeth
has to happen every day you know i hope
uh
[Laughter]
that has to happen ever if you're gonna
then look at other things
i would i would default to the ones that
are exciting for you okay
that you can also do without needing
tons of gear equipment team production
because that's when things start to get
overwhelming and impossible yeah
so
doing a tick tock live is so much easier
to do than to do a massage therapy
joke setup with
three cameras and multiple microphones
and everything else
what do you think about um
man on the street stuff like how how
difficult is that to produce with good
audio and because we we just kind of
tried it but we were getting ambient
noise
so is it a two like if we had one of
those little zoom things that's portable
and then two mics
would that be sufficient
so it depends one depends on how good
you are man on the street stuff right
and how much do you like and is it fun
pretty good good so that's a good start
uh two then the easiest way to start is
with just with a single microphone just
make sure it has like a a cover like a
windscreen yeah it's kind of a way
and so your pat you hold it and you pass
it back and forth
the problem with that is that's the
easiest thing to do the challenge with
that is
uh if if they say something while you're
talking or you you you have to make sure
that the voices always come in here or
you don't hear it exactly so if you have
the mic on them and you want to crack
some joke you have to bring it back to
you so there's a little bit of getting
used to that
but
also like man on the street if if you
need them to come in and then you're
going to mic them up
you've already lost it right if you want
to have a second mic that then you're
they have to hold yeah it adds a level
of complexity
um
but the easiest thing you still need a
camera person
and then you need you need the
microphone right so the microphone's not
that expensive
basic microphone with a like a
windscreen is a couple bucks like it
doesn't have to cost a lot but we're
adding levels of complexity now where
you have to have somebody with you yeah
who's going to set up the camera and
film it for you
and then there's editing
out all of the
moments and waiting and you know so
that's a fun project like you put that
into the fun bucket
which is good like fun is great you know
it's like we add that on top of the
on top of the the daily you know what
we're doing all of these ideas can work
there's no rules right i mean
for me that would suck for me to like
walk up on someone on somebody said hey
and like have some joke to tell them oh
my gosh
it is awful no you know what i have to
tell you i'm actually i guess i'm an
ambivert but it's horrifying but when
like jessica and i we normally riff and
i just started talking to people and
then if that's what but but approaching
people is is horrifying but i thought
about people with dogs like i could
roast your dog um
things like that but um
it wound up being you know like i wound
up having deep conversations with some
people it started off you know some of
it was funny but you're right it needed
to be edited the funny part needed to be
edited afterward so
if you're gonna roast somebody i would
honestly look at like look at news
like load up google news and see what's
trending and roast whoever roast bite
and roast trump roast
putin like whatever is the front page of
google news or front page of the new
york times every day as long as you have
enough to say about it you pull it up
and you put the camera on on the page
like again it doesn't have to be edited
you take your phone
show the screen and say
biden whatever you wanna i think i think
fitness stuff is funny i think the whole
because i'm into it but i mean it's like
it's a bit difficult to you know take it
also very seriously you know all the
wellness movement you know
but um i think that's a fun thing to
make or to roast there's two buckets
there's the like the blocking and
tackling this has to happen there's the
daily has to happen it's like you
wouldn't go outside naked you got to put
some clothes on right so like this is
our this is liz putting her clothes on
is we're going to do the three tick
tocks and ig reels a day we're going to
do a weekly show inside of our facebook
group we're going to ask for tips and
we're going to ask for help and like hey
if you know anybody who needs a
community to open up that's our that's
our getting dressed every day okay and
then after that's done then fun whatever
yeah man on the street rose some fitness
influencers
load up google news and all of that can
work there's no rules with that just
default to trying to get into action
mode as opposed to oh here's an idea but
then instantly like oh there's all these
reasons why i can't do it because i need
you know me so well this is a that
you're
telling me everything that like it's
you're breaking it down so simply it's
really helpful because i mean i thought
well that's ridiculous that i can't do
x y and z thing because i can see it i
can see all these things and you know
but to actually implement them i mean
it's it is overwhelming for me well and
just understand that it's not a no it's
just a not yet yeah
there's a sequence that's all because
if you get if you just do the the
blocking
the basics that we talked about
then you start to build enough money to
pay your rent and pay your bills and and
then and then build more money to hire a
team who can then help you do all this
stuff right and so these are all the
ideas that are round two when you have
budget and you have one person to help
you and then round three will be even
bigger things in round four and then liz
is at a giant stadium selling it out you
know so
there's it's not no it's not that it's
not possible it's totally possible yeah
it's just a lot easier to go in sequence
and so it's not yet because if you get
that those first things down that then
you can afford to hire a team then
everything else becomes a lot easier
afterwards
were you going to say something else
because you said there's two there's two
pieces one you said this was the
brushing the teeth thing or whatever and
i don't know what the other thing was
well in in the brushing of teeth it does
the brush and teeth does two things
it it gets you paid
yes because you're asking for tips and
asking for help but it's also building
your brand
because now if you're doing three a day
on both tick tock and instagram reels
more people will start to discover you
and great things will happen from that
that you can't expect
like you can expect great things but you
don't know where it's gonna go yeah
should i even try to deal with uh
linkedin
uh i wouldn't worry about linkedin too
much
because everyone's on their phone
looking at tick-tock
yeah and like that's what works like if
you only did tick-tock instagram i'd be
worried because it's like where does it
like it's a
it's like a it's a hope and pray thing
it's like okay if i keep doing it
eventually it's gonna work out and it
will but like when's it gonna work out
everyone's like oh i don't know like you
gotta keep going but one of them will
pop and we'll hit
but if you can combine it with the
facebook group
where you're doing a weekly show and
getting tips and getting paid yeah now
we have a fantastic
one-two punch strategy yeah and and that
honestly doesn't even take a ton of time
no i know that's the problem
and ig's a day or there's not a lot of
time like 45 seconds not not edited just
go and film it is not an insane amount
of time especially once you get into the
the rhythm and habit of it that's way
easier than producing a podcast or going
up and do men in the street and then
editing it like so much easier and and
it speaks to your skill set and
strengths yeah
and most importantly start getting the
momentum that you need yeah
you're so right now it's time to act hey
i love it this is great in the house i
appreciate you thank you have a good day
thank you so much to see me coach
another entrepreneur one on one check
the video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there definitely like
you're on a super hot topic how i like
to think about content is it's great to
build an audience but it's better if i
if you understand the business model to
hey let's get an audience where you can
then convert to the thing that you're
trying to sell right